Nos piden resolver para "y"
y nos dan menos la raíz cúbica de "y"
es igual a 4 la raíz cúbica de "y" más 5.
En este tipo de ecuaciones lo primero que hacemos
es dejar de un lado solo los radicales,
y a partir de ahí eliminar dichos radicales.
Para esta ecuación, lo más fácil es que pasemos
los radicales del lado izquierdo,
para esto vamos a restar
4 raíz cúbica de "y" a ambos lados,
restamos raíz cúbica...
no, no,
necesitamos restar -4 raíz cúbica de "y",
ya está del lado izquierdo
y también lo hacemos del lado derecho,
-4 raíz cúbica de "y",
así que del lado izquierdo nos queda,
tenemos menos la raíz cúbica de "y"menos 4
la raíz cúbica de "y"
si tenemos menos una raíz cúbica de "y"
y le agregamos -4 raíz cúbica de "y",
nos queda menos 5 raíz cúbica de "y"
y del lado derecho
estos dos términos se cancelan.
Eso era lo que queríamos originalmente,
dejar la raíz cúbica de "y" tan solo del lado izquierdo,
así es que esto nos queda únicamente igual a 5,
este 5 que tenemos acá
y ya casi dejamos sola la raíz cúbica de "y",
tan solo nos falta dividir ambos lados entre -5.
Hagamos eso, dividimos entre -5 el lado izquierdo
y dividimos entre -5 el lado derecho,
este - 5 y -5 se cancelan,
y nos queda del lado izquierdo la raíz cúbica de "y"
y del lado derecho 5 entre -5 es igual a -1.
Ahora,
podríamos... la manera más fácil y directa
sería elevar al cubo ambos lados
para obtener entonces la solución de esta ecuación,
o también podemos considerar que esto es equivalente,
esta expresión es equivalente
a "y" a la 1/3 es igual a -1,
son dos maneras equivalentes de establecer lo mismo,
pues "y" a la 1/3 es lo mismo que raíz cúbica de "y",
así es que elevando al cubo
a ambos lados de la ecuación,
elevamos al cubo ambos lados de la ecuación,
también lo vamos a hacer aquí con esta ecuación equivalente,  elevamos al cubo ambos lados,
¿Qué obtenemos?
Bueno, aquí tenemos "y" a la 1/3 elevado al cubo,
es lo mismo que elevar "y" a la 1/3 por 3,
esto es lo mismo que elevar "y" a la primera potencia,
lo mismo que tenemos acá,
si sacamos la raíz cúbica de "y"
y luego elevamos al cubo,
las operaciones se cancelan para obtener finalmente
"y" igual a - 1 al cubo,
-1 al cubo es -1 por -1, es 1 positivo,
por -1 es igual a -1,
"y" igual a -1, es nuestra solución.
Ahora verifiquemos que efectivamente funciona.
Regresemos a la ecuación original
en donde en vez de "y" voy a poner -1,
tenemos
menos la raíz cúbica de "y" que es -1,
lo cual tiene que ser igual a
4 por la raíz cúbica de -1
más 5.
Veamos si esto se cumple.
La raíz cúbica de -1 es -1,
pues -1 al cubo es -1.
Así es que esto va a ser menos -1,
que tiene que ser igual a 4 por la raíz cúbica de -1,
es -1 más 5
menos -1 es 1 positivo,
esto es igual a 4 por -1 = -4 más 5,
-4 más 5 es igual a 1,
y hemos verificado exitosamente
que nuestra solución es la correcta.